one of my favorite stories i read about
you and jessie tyler ferguson was
visiting a frat house in your hometown
please tell me about it oh my gosh yes
so we went back to my alma mater kansas
state university and jesse was like
where did you live when you were here i
said well i lived in a fraternity house
he's like let's go and this was like at
12 after the bars were closing so we
just roll over and we go to my old room
knock on the door nobody answers and
check the door
go in and there is a lovely young couple
up in a bed like pull the blankets back
and i'm like hi
and this is like at the height of modern
family so they're like what the bleep is
mitch and cam are standing in their room
they they're post-coitus
of their posts post-coitus okay i see so
they're schools they're in the after
glow and bliss yes and then there you
are here we are hi
were you like i used to live here i used
to do this here
i love it i love it so much
but um okay there was also a picture of
you and one of the goddesses of all
times oh yes hey riri so like from a
dorm room bedroom to this moment oh man
this was at the women in film party at
the chateau one year right and i'm there
with lots of my friends and hank doing
the hollywood thing hanging out right
and i had seen rihanna across the room
but i'm not the person to be able to or
to go over and say anything
well at one point i look over and she's
just going like this
to me
so i walk over and her group was like
rihanna watches the show she we love it
so much and she's like asked for a
picture i'm like yes i wanted a picture
but i just didn't have the courage to
come over and ask for one
that's not the best part
what's the best part the best part is
jessie my form you know co-star and his
husband were at the party that night and
they wanted to get a picture but
jessie's did the same thing i did it's
like i'm not going over to rihanna and
bothering her for a picture i'm not
doing it so i go to work the next
morning jesse's like
eric he's like you got me in so much
trouble last night i'm like what
happened she's like the picture of you
and rihanna i'm like she asked me i
didn't i didn't do it it's not my fault
you're like it's rihanna yeah and why
would i yeah so anyway that's uh that's
my rihanna i love all of this
and i also love that you are totally
open and honest that it wasn't all bells
and whistles and easy street you were
working your butt off you were mr
commercials you were doing a ton of
commercials i have a clip i have a
commercial of you right now look there
you are oh my gosh
oh my gosh
how do i how do i look like it in like a
55 year old insurance agent 25 years ago
it's so weird it's totally the outfit by
the way they literally like it's like
almost like a cliche they're like office
guy
[Music]
you